S
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
CRIMES CAUGHT ON CAMERA SHOW
EXACTLY WHY AMERICAN CITIES ARE
UNDER SIEGE.
CHECK OUT WHAT HAPPENED IN A
WALGREENS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS IS A MAN IN BROAD DAYLIGHT
LOSING A STORY AND JUST FILLING
UP THE GARBAGE BAG.
THEN HE JUST CASUALLY RIDES HIS
BIKE OUT OF THE STORE AND UNDER
THE STREET.
WALGREENS HAS CLOSED 17 STORES
IN THE CITY BECAUSE OF THIS.
OTHER COMPANIES ARE FOLLOWING
SUIT.
THERE ARE SOME SHOCKING VIDEOS
OF A DRIVE-BY SHOOTING IN
ATLANTA'S WEALTHY BUCKHEAD
NEIGHBORHOOD.
PEOPLE ARE RUNNING FOR THEIR
LIVES WERE COPS THAT AREN'T
ALLOWED TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
THANKS TO THE RULES THAT LIMIT
POLICE FROM CHASING SUSPECTS.
RESIDENTS IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD
ARE FED UP AND THEY WANT THEIR
OWN POLICE FORCE.
>> WE ARE LIVING IN A WAR ZONE
AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE IN
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS IS AN
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS SPIKE IN
CRIME AND A COMPLETE VACUUM OF
LEADERSHIP.
THE POLICE IN ATLANTA ARE GREAT
POLICEMEN AND WOMEN, WE LOVE
THEM, THEY JUST WANT TO DO THEIR
JOB AND THEY ARE NOT BEING
ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
>> Jesse: CAN ANYBODY EXPLAIN
TO ME, MAYBE YOU CAN, GREG, WHY
A POLITICIAN WOULD PROHIBIT
POLICE FROM CHASING SUSPECTS?
ISN'T THAT JUST TELLING SUSPECTS
TO COMMIT A CRIME AND FLEE?
>> Greg: WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU
CATCH THEM AND THAT GOES AWRY
AND YOU HAVE THE MEDIA THERE,
PEOPLE HOLDING THEIR PHONES ON
GOING LIKE THIS, IT'S NOT WHERE
THEY, WHY DID YOU THINK THE
SECURITY GUARD IN THAT VIDEO AND
WALGREENS BARELY STUCK HIS HAND
OUT TO GRAB THE BAG.
FOR $20 AN HOUR IT'S NOT WORTH
RUINING HIS LIFE THE MOMENT HE
BECOMES A SUSPECT, THE MOMENT
THE MEDIA SAYS THIS POOR MAN WAS
JUST GETTING BREAD TO FEED HIS
FAMILY.
HE FILLED THE GARBAGE BAG WITH
LOADS OF BREAD AND MILK AND THE
SECURITY GUARD TACKLES HIM.
THERE IS NO INTEREST IN DOING
YOUR JOB.
THIS IS PART OF THE
TRICKLE-DOWN-OF POLICE.
WHOEVER TAKES THE PLACE WILL
ALSO BE VILIFIED, WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS A WHILE AGO, THE
PEOPLE WHO CAN AFFORD IT GO BACK
THROUGH THEIR COMMUNITIES,
HIGHER PRIVATE SECURITIES, ARMED
TO THE TEETH BECAUSE THE STATE
PERMITS A LAWLESSNESS THAT NO
ONE ELSE CAN SURVIVE.
LASTLY I WANT TO MAKE THE POINT
THAT, WHILE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THIS PRESIDENT BIDEN IS, THIS IS
HAPPENING, THIS IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING IN AMERICA THAT HE'S
INTERESTED IN THIS DOMESTIC
TERROR AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT, I KNOW THE NAMES OF MS-13,
I KNOW AL QAEDA, I KNOW ISIS,
WHO ARE THESE GIANT GANGS HE'S
TALKING ABOUT DOING THIS CRIME?
WHY ARE WE ASKING THIS QUESTION?
SOMEONE HAS TO TALK TO JILL.
>> Jesse: DR. JILL BIDEN HE IS
REFERRING TO.
DOWNTOWN AND UNION SQUARE, DANA,
WE WALKED PAST THE SITUATION, WE
SAW A HOMELESS MAN STABBED AN
OFF-DUTY POLICE OFFICER IN THE
NECK WITH A PAIR OF SCISSORS.
THIS IS BROAD DAYLIGHT, WE CAME
IN RIGHT AFTERWARDS, THE
AMBULANCE WAS RIGHT THERE.
I'VE BEEN SHOOTING IN UNION
SQUARE FOR ABOUT A DECADE AND
THIS IS NEVER HAPPENED, ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
AND THEN PEOPLE JUST WITNESS IT
AND GO ABOUT THEIR DAY.
>> Dana: IS A BIG FIGHT AT
WASHINGTON SQUARE PARK, I'VE
READ SOME THINGS THAT WERE
HAPPENING THERE THAT I COULD NOT
EVEN BELIEVE ARE PRINTED IN A
NEWSPAPER AND NOW THEY ARE
BLAMING THE NEIGHBORS FOR
COMPLAINING, HOW DARE YOU
COMPLAIN THAT THIS IS HAPPENING?
THE OTHER THING THAT'S HAPPENING
IS GUESS WHO IS NOW THE VILLAIN
IN SAN FRANCISCO?
WALGREENS BECAUSE THEY CLOSED
STORES.
I WAS JUST LOOKING AT THIS, HE
WAS RESPONDING TO A GUY WHO SAID
"WALGREENS REALLY IS AT FAULT."
WHERE THEY HAVE ALL?
OF WHAT THEY LIED AND THEY ARE
CLOSING STORES WANT TO MAKE MORE
MONEY," WE ARE WATCHING THIS
HAPPEN RIGHT THERE.
THE OTHER THING IS FROM A BIGGER
PERSPECTIVE ALL ACROSS AMERICA
THERE'S BEEN THIS PUSH AND WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS A LITTLE BIT,
DONORS ON THE LEFT HAVE PUSHED
FOR A VERY PROGRESSIVE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND WHAT HAPPENS THEN?
YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT WAY OF
PUNISHMENT FOR CRIMES.
IT COULD BE ON ONE END, ATLANTA,
THE CITY COUNCILS HAVE DECIDED,
DON'T HAVE THE POLICE CHASED THE
SUSPECT BECAUSE IF YOU END UP
INJURING AN INNOCENT PERSON IN
THE CHASE THAT ENDS UP CAUSING
EVEN MORE PROBLEMS AND YOU CAN
TRY TO CATCH THE CRIMINAL LATER.
THE TWO WE HAVE A DUANE READE
NEAR MY PLACE IN THE CITY THE
CITY.
>> Kennedy: GREAT GUY.
>> Jesse: I CALL THIS GUY THE
WHITE CLUB BANDIT, HE WILL COME
INTO THE STORE, LOAD UP WITH A
CASE OF WHITE CLAW AND RUN OUT
OF THE STORE.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO STOP HIM,
YOU CAN EVEN STICK YOUR FOOT OUT
AND TRIPPED THEM.
>> Kennedy: HE WILL SUE YOU?
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE TO CALL THE
POLICE AND THEY WRITE THAT OFF
AS A CASE OF WHITE CLOTH, THAT'S
THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS.
I USUALLY NEVER SEE THIS.
>> Kennedy: IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S THE
INSIDIOUS NEST OF MARXISM, I
REALLY DO.
IT'S THE IDEA OF REDISTRIBUTION
THAT'S TAKEN HOLD SO PEOPLE HEAR
THAT AND THEY HEAR THAT SORT OF
REINFORCED ALL DAY LONG.
MAINSTREAM DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING
ABOUT DIFFERENT WAYS OF
REDISTRIBUTING, PATRIOT TAX, WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE YOUR WELL THEN
GIVE IT OUT, THAT'S GREAT, THESE
CORPORATIONS ARE RICH, I'M GOING
TO TAKE THEIR STUFF AND SELL IT
AND MAKE MONEY AND THAT MEANS
THAT THE SYSTEM IS SORT OF
UPSIDE DOWN.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT I
DESPISE MARXISM BECAUSE IT TAKES
THE IDEA OF PRIVATE PROPERTY AND
IT FEELS THIS IS JUSTIFIED,
CYNTHIA NIXON, THE LEAST LIKABLE
CHARACTER ON "SEX AND THE CITY,"
SHE RAN FOR --
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT IT WAS
MR. BIG.
>> Kennedy: EVERYBODY LOVES
BIG.
SHE WAS, STOP ARRESTING PEOPLE
FOR SHOPLIFTING, POOR PEOPLE
NEED STUFF AND ALL THESE POOR
PEOPLE ATTACKER ON TWITTER, I
DON'T MAKE A LOT OF MONEY AND I
DON'T STEAL STUFF, BACK OFF,
LADY.
THERE IS NO MORE UNIFORM
DISTRIBUTIVE STANDARDS.
>> Jesse: IT AFFECTS ME
BECAUSE NOW I GO TO DUANE READE
AND EVERYTHING IS LOCKED UP
BEHIND THE COUNTER.
I HAD TO PUSH A BUTTON, WAIT FOR
A WOMAN TO COME OVER AND UNLOCK
IT, GETTING FLOSS OR SOMETHING
ELSE THAT I DON'T WANT ANYBODY
ELSE TO SEE AND EVERYTHING IS
LOCKED DOWN.
>> Richard: I THINK THE FACT
THAT STORES LOCKED DOWN THESE
PRODUCTS IS VERY TERRIBLE.
WITH THAT BEING SAID I DO THINK,
YOU KNOW, WE DO HAVE A SPIKE IN
CRIME AND WE NEED TO HAVE A
LARGER CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
WORK WITH COMMUNITIES TO SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, THE PROBLEM
IS THIS POLICY THAT WE HAVE,
WHETHER YOU CALL IT ANTI-POLICE
POLICY, MAYBE BRINGING IN
COMMUNITY, BRINGING IN
LAWMAKERS, BRINGING IN POLICE
COVER WE DON'T WANT TO BE A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALLS, WE
DON'T WANT TO BE AT DRUG ABUSE
CALLS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRAINED TO DEAL WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
>> Greg: SOCIAL WORKERS.
>> Richard: GRIEF COUNSELORS
AND PEOPLE WHO DEAL WITH THIS
WORK ALL DAY.
>> Jesse: IF THERE'S A
DRIVE-BY SHOOTING --
>> Richard: IF THERE'S A
DRIVE-BY SHOOTING YOU SEND
POLICE.
THE REASON POLICE DON'T CHASE
FOR OBVIOUS REASONS IS BECAUSE
OFTEN TIMES COMMUNITY MEMBERS
GET CAUGHT IN THE CROSSHAIRS AND
END UP BEING THE VICTIMS.
SHE WAS JUST A VICTIM.
SHE WAS SLEEPING IN HER BED WAS
KILLED BECAUSE THEY WERE LOOKING
FOR SOMEONE ELSE.
THEY HAD A NO KNOCK WARRANT TO
THE WRONG ADDRESS.
TO BE TO HAVE SOMEONE STEAL
SOMETHING OR SHOOT SOMEBODY IN
THE STREET, POLICE HAVE TO
PURSUE TO APPREHEND THAT PERSON,
ARE THEY GOING TO WAIT AROUND
UNTIL THIS GUY SHOWS HIS FACE ON
A SURVEILLANCE CAMERA?
>> Richard: HOW MANY
HIGH-SPEED CHASES WERE INNOCENT
CITIZENS GET HURT?
>> Jesse: I WOULD DISAGREE
WITH THE FACT THAT IT'S A LARGE
PERCENTAGE.
>> Greg: THE IDEA OF COMMUNITY
POLICE WORKING TOGETHER, A LOT
OF MINORITY-MAJORITY FORCES, THE
BLACK LEADERS HAVE TO RESIGN.
THE SPECIFIC ACTIVIST MENTALITY,
AS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Richard: WHAT THEY DID IN
THEIR SENTIMENT IS THEY ACTUALLY
PUSHED A THE LOUISVILLE POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SOME
NECESSARY CHANGES, ONE OF THOSE
CHANGES AS IF YOU ARE A POLICE
OFFICER THAT SERVES ON THE
LOUISVILLE POLICE DEPARTMENT
THEY ASK YOU TO LIVE WHERE YOU
WORK.
AN EASY THING --
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T DO THAT IN
NEW YORK.
>> Kennedy: VAL DEMINGS, THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT HAVING HER AS
JOE BIDEN'S NUMBER TWO AND
ACTIVISTS WERE LIKE NO, SHE IS
BLUE, SHE IS NO LONGER BLACK.
THE CHIEF OF POLICE IN SEATTLE
WAS FORCED OUT OF HER JOB --
>> Richard: I ACTUALLY LIKE
VAL DEMINGS AND WHEN YOU LISTEN
TO WHAT VAL DEMINGS DID AS SHE
WENT INTO THE COMMUNITIES AND
HAD CONVERSA